half century old Cold Case that appears
to have been closed this week police in
Burlington Vermont say they now know who
killed a 24 year old woman on a summer
night back in 1971. Michael George is
here with how investigators Crack the
Case Michael good morning well Jeff good
morning like so many of these cases it
was DNA that solved this mystery the
suspected killer leaving a clue at the
crime scene that wasn't able to be
unlocked until now
the crime horrified the City of
Burlington Vermont in July 1971 and
haunted investigators for more than 50
years Rita Curran a 24 year old
elementary school teacher was found
beaten strangled and sexually assaulted
in the bedroom of the apartment she
shared with roommates someone entered
through an unlocked door finding current
at home and alone Curran's Sister Mary
was 22 years old at the time I don't
know what she would have been like when
she was 35 or 40. I I don't
I don't have that image because she's
always 24 years old to me the case
confounded investigators for decades
then the years rolled into decades even
though we might not ever give up hope
that we really felt at this point
the person was probably dead
and that we would never know
who did it until 2014 when a retired
detective sent an object found near
Curran's body to be analyzed for DNA the
cigarette butt had been dropped there
and burned out on the floor next to her
body the DNA on the cigarette butt
offered a genetic profile of whomever
smoked it but didn't lead to a name in a
database that came years later when a
DNA testing company traced the sample
through family members to William derus
who was 31 years old in 1971 and lived
in the apartment above Rita Curran we
were numb it's like oh
51 and a half years and it's the guy
upstairs derus's wife in 1971 says he
left their apartment that night after a
fight but that he convinced her to
maintain his Alibi the husband and wife
gave each other alibis
five decades later she told our
detectives a different story the truth
despite what police say is Rock Solid
evidence William derus will not be held
accountable today William derus would be
83.
but there is not a cop in this building
who would not happily put handcuffs on
him
instead he died in San Francisco in 1986
15 years after murdering Rita while they
won't receive Justice for Rita's murder
Mary Curran says her close-knit family
is what got her through the past half
century of pain I had only 22 years
and it's been 50.
my children never knew her
my grandchildren never knew her and
they're the ones that people say how do
you get through it how did you get
through it
playing a lot of rocks holding me up
and throughout the 52 years this case
was opened Burlington Police never gave
up on it at one point they even zeroed
in on the notorious serial killer Ted
Bundy but at this point the reason they
solved this case is because they held on
to that evidence including that
cigarette butt that led them to who they
believe is the killer it's amazing with
all of these DNA things that people go
through now suddenly you can find
something we've seen it over and over
again those ancestry and genealogy DNA
sites leading to a DNA match fascinating
thank you Michael